morning we are now on page 582 we're
going to start test number four so let's
start with the first problem problem
number one problem number one when Miss
Yun arrived at the grocery store there
were five packages of hot dog rolls left
on the shelf one package contained 12
rolls and each of the other packages
contained a troll so there's five
packages one contained 12 rolls 12 rolls
and then the other 44 contained eight
rolls right because there's five total
if Miss you in but all five packages how
many hot dog rolls did you purchase at
the store so it's 12 12 rolls from that
one plus 4 times 8 that's 32 so two plus
two is four then 44 so she bought 44
rolls and that's choice C the hardest
part there is just the multiplication
number to a B and C are points on a line
in that order if a okay let's let's draw
that so there's my line okay so a B and
C are points online a b c if a B equals
30 a B is equal to 30 and BC is 20 more
than a B so bc is what its twenty more
than this so it's 50 right what does AC
equal so what is this equal what's just
30 plus 50 it's 80 that is choice D next
question and I will change colors
problem number three if X plus 3 is
equal to a then what is 2x plus 6 equal
so that the really fast way of doing
this is you say well you know what to X
plus 6 that's the same thing as 2 times
X plus 3 all right and what's two times
X plus 3 well X plus 3 is a so this is
going to equal to x a and that's choice
C and that's the fast way to do it I
mean you could have done you know x is
equal to a minus 3 and then substituted
this in here and said two times a minus
three plus six to a minus 6 plus 6 and
you got into a this would have taken you
like 15 extra of precious seconds on the
s.a.d so if you saw this immediately
this would have been a better way to do
it but this would have also been a
correct way the next question looks like
the next couple question I have to do
some drawing for it okay so they plot a
bunch of point I'm trying to figure out
how I can draw the minimum I don't have
to draw the whole thing so that's the y
axis x axis c scores on tests so i'm
just going to draw the points that look
like so so i don't have to draw the
whole thing so you have points a point
be here now Point C and then they have
and they have point D here and then have
an E which it looks like the same level
this to be point E and so we get where
we are so this is this line right here
that's a 60 and then they draw another
line right here and then this point
right here is 80 that's 80 and then
this line down here looks like roughly
let's see it's 40 and where the sea is
looks like there's one line here and
then the sea is there's a 60 line and
there's a 80 there and in the book it
says this is this the x-axis is score on
test one score test one and then the
y-axis is test to score on tests do I
know you can't read what I wrote but you
can look at it in your book score on
test two so these are test scores of
five students so problem number 4 asks
us for which student was the change in
scores from test one two tests to the
greatest so which student either did
really bad on test one and then improve
to test two or did really good on tests
one and then kind of degraded well let's
see let's look at the chart so beat
student be scored a 40 on test so let me
write all the choice let's do actually
in order so what was the change for a
and these aren't the choices these are
just actually the choices are the same
as as the letters so a got a 40 on test
one right got a 40 on test one just read
it here and got a 70 on test two so the
change is 30 B got a 40 on test one and
a 60 on test two it's changes 20c got a
60 and a 70 this 10d got an 80 and and
80 so it's no difference and then you
got then 80 and a 60 or minus 20 but the
change is still just 20 we can write
minus 20 but the biggest change is
choice a got a 40 and then got a 70 so
really improved on that second test and
number five what was the average the
arithmetic mean of this of the scores of
the five students on test two on test
two so these the y-axis is test two so
let's just write it out for us to nay
got a 70 70 student B got a 60
the students II got a 70 student d got
an 82 an e you got a 60 + 60 I know if
you can read that and then there are
five points right so let's see we could
just pretend like this is a this is a
student that's a 60 I already so let's
see what's 7 plus 7 is 14 plus six is
twenty plus eight is 28 plus six is
thirty four so it's 340 / 5 340 / 5 and
that equals 15 goes into 360 68 that's
the average or the iron thematic mean
and that's choice C problem number six
problem number six okay they do a bunch
of stuff i guess i should draw it too
that's the line they drew and keeps
going like that let's see i have so it
goes from minus 2 22 so it's minus 2
minus 10 12 and extra space they draw a
bunch of points which I'll do in a
different color so this is T and they've
uvw all here u v w u v w and they put an
X here X and Y Z is why and there's Z Y
and then Z they ask us on the number
line above TUV wxy and z our coordinates
of the indicated points which of the
following is closest to the value of the
absolute value of U plus V so this is
just an approximation problem so you
just have to kind of look at this and
get
what u and v are so it looks like you
you is about three-fourths the way to
negative one right so I'm just going to
assume that u is equal or approximately
equal like the squiggly equal you
approximately equals negative
three-fourths right because it's almost
at negative 1 and then V looks halfway
between 0 and negative 1 so that looks
about negative one-half right i don't
know if that's exact negative one-half
so what's the absolute value of minus
three fourths minus one-half well that's
equal to the absolute value get a common
denominator of minus 3 minus 2 over 4
right and equals the absolute value of
minus 54 it's the absolute value of
minus 5 for its is equal to 5 over 4 and
if we look at if we look at the choices
5 over 4 that's a little bit more than
one right that's equal to one and
one-fourth one and one-fourth one and
one-fourth this is one so a little bit
more than one looks like choice why is
our best answer so that is choice number
D see you in the next video